controversy
great is the mystery of godliness
god was manifest in the flesh
today
we will be discussing the humanity of
christ
this is q a with elder randy skeet on
the word inspired i am your host denise
mccurchion let's have a word of prayer
dear lord
thank you for this opportunity to ponder
this unfathomable concept that you would
send your only begotten son who is god
in the form of human flesh
please
send your holy spirit
speak to us and in a special way anoint
your manservant elder randy skeet put
your words in his mouth dear lord and
may we all leave here with a better
understanding
of who you are and your plan for our
lives in jesus name we pray amen
all right joining us today is none other
than elder randy skeet he is a true man
of god who not only takes the gospel all
around the world but is intent on
building individual relationships with
the persons that he meets and i can
testify of that he is as you would see
in his uh messages he is a nice man a
man who patterns his life after the life
of christ and today he will be answering
our questions on the humanity of christ
and of course elder skeet has studied
for the ministry he attended uh the
oakwood university and the theological
seminary at andrews university and here
he is joining us today to answer these
questions on the humanity of christ i
pray that you
think as he speaks listen intently and
specifically ask god to put his words in
elderskeets now please welcome elder
randy
skeet
oh
can you hear me
we can hear you all right
let me say publicly how honored i am to
be a part of this program as always and
i say that with concentrated seriousness
i believe it is a very blessed ministry
god has entrusted to you
and i hope that this ministry will be
the means whereby god opens the eyes of
untold thousands of people to the truth
that is essential for their
sanctification and for their salvation
so thanks again for allowing me to be a
part of this
i'm ready for the questions when you're
ready to deliver them
amen thank you so much elder skeet for
joining us and i'll pray one more time
for you lord god continue to bless your
manservant and continue to put your
words in his mouth in jesus name we pray
amen amen
the first question is
how do we know that jesus was human
very very fair legitimate question
when christ rose from the dead if we can
go to luke 24 we'll read from verse 36
the disciples were in an upper room
cowering from fear of the jews
the bible says as they thus speak jesus
himself stood in the midst of them and
saith unto them
peace be unto you
but they were terrified unafraid
and supposed that they had seen a spirit
and he said of them why are you troubled
and why do thoughts arise in your heart
behold my hands and my feet it is i
myself
handle me and see for a spirit hath not
flesh and bones as ye see me have christ
was attempting to prove his
physicality if i may use that term i'm
real i'm a human being touch me look at
my hands look at my feet in john's
version he says they looked at his his
side where he was pierced by the roman
soldier
when they were not convinced
he said to them have ye hear any meat
verse 42.
and they gave him a piece of a broiled
fishing of a hariko man and he took it
and didn't eat before them in other
words in their presence they watched him
eat as he attempted to prove he was
human he was physical
because they thought they had seen a
ghost
you see in verse 37 he wanted to prove i
am no ghost i am flesh and blood i am
human i have the marks of the
crucifixion and so christ himself was
over eager to prove that he was human
but even before that
matthew 1 21 the angel told joseph in a
vision or dream
and she shall bring forth a son
thou shall call his name jesus for he
shall save his people from this sin
verse 23 essentially repeats the same
thing behold a virgin shall be with
child a woman does not become pregnant
with an angel
human beings give birth to human beings
this is the law of creation in genesis
1. trees produce trees animals produce
animals cats produce cats dogs produce
dog mary produce a human being but the
mystery of that event was that that
human being was also god and as you said
so correctly it is a profound mystery
but we must undertake a study of this
mystery because understanding the
humanity of christ is
indispensable to our salvation and so
christ was born of a woman galatians 4 4
but when the fullness of time was come
god sent forth his son made of a woman
made under the law he was born of a
woman she was pregnant with him for nine
months and she gave birth jesus christ
according to the biblical record was
a human being as verily as he was 100
percent god
mystery of mysteries but we must study
it
amen amen thank you elder skeet i like
how you highlighted that humans give
birth to humans
and if we look back at genesis chapter 3
verse 15
god promised that he would send of the
seed of the woman which was
humanity
to be the savior of the world so god in
keeping his promise sent his son in the
form of a human babe to save us as we
see in matthew 1 verses 21 and 23. let
me say something else
there's the possibility of someone
appearing to be human but not fully
human for instance in genesis 18 from
verse 1
and the lord appeared unto him in the
plains of memory and he sat in the tent
door in the heat of the day and he
lifted his eyes and looked and behold
three men stood by him and when he saw
them he ran to beat them from the tent
door and bowed himself toward the ground
this was abraham seeing three men he did
not know at that time the three men were
christ and two angels he prevailed upon
them to accept his hospitality they
accepted and in verse 8 he said them in
verse 7 and abraham ran under herd and
fetched a calf tender good he gave it
unto young man to dress
and he took the cathedral dress and
brought her on milk and gave it to them
he stood by them under the tree and they
did eat now they were in human form
zdd you see now it was eating that
christ also used to demonstrate i am
physical because he told the disciples
give me something to eat and so we have
christ eating in genesis 18 we have
christ eating in luke 24 but the
difference is the christ in genesis 18
did not come through a woman he just
took on the appearance of a human being
he did not have human nature the christ
of the new testament was born of a woman
and consequently had human nature he was
fully human so there's a difference
between taking on the appearance of a
human being which christ did and the
angels did but in the new testament
christ was literally genetically the
result of some mysterious process
whereby god appeared in the womb of
woman and the woman gave birth to god
jesus christ being god and human and so
yes christ was fully human
amen amen
mother skeet i'm i'm being led to just
read philippians chapter two verses five
through eight
quickly uh flip to that passage it's one
of my favorite uh
texts in the bible actually
philippians chapter 2 verses 5 through 8
here's what the bible says
let this mind be in you which was also
in christ jesus
who being in the form of god thought it
not robbery to be equal with god but
made himself of no reputation and took
upon him the form of a servant and was
made in the likeness or the habit of men
and being found in fashion as a man he
humbled himself and became obedient unto
death
even the death of the cross
indeed jesus was human yes he was
now elder skeet
we have shown through scripture
jesus
took the form of a human and mccain took
on even the the nature of humanity
is there extra biblical evidence or
historical evidence
that jesus was human
yes there is
some disputed
some more reliable uncertain
josephus that jewish historian
who served the jews and the romans as it
as it were to his advantage he mentions
christ
in his writings
josephus was present at the destruction
of jerusalem he actually worked on the
side of the romans trying to negotiate
with the jews to surrender the romans
didn't trust him because he was a jew
the jews hated him because he was
working for the romans but he was
present he was born five years after
jesus christ uh went back to heaven so
josephus mentions christ there's a roman
historian called tacitus tacitus also
mentions christ and testis was born
about 54 about 20 something years after
jesus christ went back to heaven now the
thing about tacitus's mention of christ
is that tacitus at one point was a
member of a college of priests and one
of their functions was to monitor
cults and their regarded cults as any
religious group that did not follow the
roman gods and the christians were
regarded as a cult and tacitus mentions
a jesus christ there's another roman
historian called swetonius who also
mentions jesus christ and so there are
reliable extra biblical references
that that prove the historical reality
of this man called jesus christ
he's also mentioned in the talmud which
is a jewish writing and the talmud does
not use him favorably but it mentions
him
amen thank you so much for bringing out
those points elder skeet because indeed
you mentioned tacitus you mentioned
flavius josephus they both mentioned
jesus and all and you rightly said that
they may not have mentioned jesus
favorably but because he existed they
had no choice but to acknowledge that he
was honest but we must remember that the
bible cannot be separated from history
or history from the bible the god of the
bible is the god of history he directs
history we may not understand that but
god has the final say in the flow of
historical events he decided that
babylon would be followed by leader
persia be the person by grief he decided
that he sets the bounds of the
habitation and so you cannot shut god
out of secular history because history
is merely prophecy fulfilled and so on
that basis alone there has to be
extra biblical mention of jesus christ
there has to be because the god of the
bible is the god of history and that god
is jesus christ
amen amen thank you elder skeet
we are now going to move on to our next
question and i think one of our uh
attendees on zoom has preempted the
question in asking
well in saying jesus did not have the
genetic propensity to sin like a blank
uh like a blank slate did this play a
part in his ability to resist sin now
i'm gonna pause there because in my
research i i found
that there has been a discrepancy or two
views
apparently in the adventist church
concerning the nature of christ's
humanity um namely a pre-lab syrian view
or a post-lapse syrian view where some
believe that jesus took the form of adam
before he sinned as sovereign hero has
said like a blank slate or that jesus
took the form of adam after he sinned in
uh the sinfulness of humanity
so let me ask the question now that i
have written
did jesus take
the human nature of adam from before
or after the fall
well the bible cannot answer that very
clearly
if you read
romans 3 verse 19
the bible says now we know that what
things so ever the lord saith it says to
those who are under the law that every
mouth may be stopped and all the world
may become guilty before god those who
are under the law
romans 4 4 said when the fullness of
time was come come god sent forth his
son made a woman made under the law so
jesus christ came in our condition adam
before the fall did not need to be saved
or redeemed are you following me there
was no need for adam before the fall to
be saved in bible commentary volume
seven page nine twenty six paragraph
three element writes these words
the nature of god
whose law was transgressed
and the nature of adam the transgressor
meet in jesus christ let me say it again
the nature of god
whose law was transgressed
and the nature of adam the transgressor
meet in christ so the nature of adam the
transgressor not adam the sinless one
adam the transgressor that nature and
the perfect nature of god they meet
mysteriously in jesus christ christ took
the nature that contained the
possibility and the potential and the
weaknesses that we have
when we try to you see
what love what some advocates do they
take a slightly catholic view to the
nature of jesus christ here's what i
mean
i believe this in 1854 a pope issued
what is called the immaculate conception
he declared ex-cathedral speaking from a
position of authority that
mary
was preserved from the frailties of
human nature you see
the immaculate conception is the birth
of mary mary was born differently so
when she gave birth to christ christ was
different and mary's nature was above
the nature of the average human being
consequently christ was removed he's
above the average human being if that's
the case he cannot be an example and
many advocates have this catholic
tendency in their view of jesus christ
jesus mary was not removed in her nature
whatsoever mary had the fallen nature
she inherited from ancestors before her
going all the way back to adam
jesus coming through mary he followed he
he came in subjection to the laws of
heredity and he inherited that nature
while preserving his uh divinity but
always keep in mind that jesus christ
was made this and made that and made he
was made single second corinthians 5 21
he was made under the law he himself
never chose to sin but what he was made
was absolutely real he was made what we
are that he might take the guilt the
punishment and the blame for our sins
and that is
it is that that guarantees our salvation
when we accept it by faith or accept him
as our savior and give ourselves to him
100 percent jesus christ took the nature
of adam after he fell
amen because adam before he fell did not
need a savior
indeed indeed in elder screen i just
want to read
uh romans 8 verses 1 to 3.
and i know we love verse 1 it says there
is therefore now the holy spirit
to speak and lead and jesus is amen the
bible says there is therefore now no
condemnation to them which are in christ
jesus
who walk not after the flesh but after
the spirit verse 2
for the law of the spirit of life in
christ jesus hath made me free from the
law of sin and death now
listen very carefully to verse three
for what the law could not do
in that it was weak through the flesh
god sending his own son in the likeness
of sinful flesh
and for sin
condemned sin in the flesh this is verse
4 that the righteousness of the law
might be fulfilled in us who walk not
after the flesh but after the spirit and
the operative phrase is that god sent
jesus in
sinful
flesh
not in the nature of adam before the
fall so jesus did not begin or live
without the uh
he came in sinful nature he did not take
the human nature of adam before the fall
what people don't realize when you
remove the nature of christ to a level
above the ordinary human being you
weaken the power of the gospel you
undermine the glorious nature of this
the righteousness of jesus of god we
undermine it the marvelous thing about
the gospel which we and angels will
study all eternity is that the life of
god
can be expressed in a sinful human being
by sinful i mean having that fallen
nature right now the life of god i say
again can be expressed in someone who
carries the backpack of the sinful
nature not someone who's continually
sinning that's not a representation of
christ but the righteousness of god can
be expressed
in someone in other words from the
highest to the lowest now when you try
to elevate the lowest you interfere with
the marvelous nature of the gospel
christ came down to the gutter where we
are took that nature and in that nature
by total dependence on his father and
obeying the father by the father's power
he expressed the very life of his father
and the bible tells us this is possible
for us if we unite ourselves to christ
as christ was united to the father
christ's victorious life was the result
of total trust in his father in other
words in his humanity he conquered sin
through the word through the spirit and
by total dependence upon the father this
is where we fall short very few people
are totally surrendered to god then we
turn around and try to weaken the gospel
to accommodate our partial surrender we
must not do that if we are as
surrendered to god as jesus was the life
jesus lived is the life we will live
amen amen and i really like how you
brought it home elder skeet because the
reason jesus had to have taken the form
of human nature when we were sinning in
that sinful flesh is to show that we too
through his power can have that same
victory over sin
and i just want to end with this
quotation from desire of ages page 48 it
says it would have been an almost
infinite humiliation
for the son of god to take man's nature
even when adam stood in his innocence
but jesus
accepted humanity when the race had been
weakened by 4 000.
but let me say something quickly there's
a difference between sinful and
sinfulness
you see sinfulness refers to constantly
sinning that is sinful mess jesus never
took that he never sins he never sinned
he took a fallen nature he took the
nature we had but he never sinned and
sinned and sinned he never took our
sinfulness either our sinful nature not
our sinfulness he had no propensity to
sin in the sense that you see there's
some people they are called
kleptomaniacs they have a propensity for
stealing they steal all the time all the
time almost pathologically now not all
sinners have that but some sinners are
kleptomaniac some people have
pathological liars they'll lie about
everything they'll tell you that grass
is pink instead of green because they
are pathological liars it's a it's a
pattern of behavior christ had no
pattern of sinful behavior he had no
propensity no proclivity despite the
fact he had the nature and so when we
sin and sin and sin we develop a
propensity we develop a proclivity
someone smokes a marijuana joint then
develops an addiction that becomes a
propensity of proclivity because it
began with one act that's why the bible
says in ephesians 5 some things we
should not even do once christ did not
take our sinfulness in the sense that we
sin all the time all the time either our
sinful nature not our sinful behavior
because the sinful nature does not mean
sinful behavior when you come to christ
because the purpose of christ is to show
that the presence of the sinful nature
does not have to eventuate in sinful
behavior i've always said that clearly
possessing the sinful nature does not
mean i have to live a life of sinful
behavior sinful possessing the sinful
nature sorry does not mean i have to
practice a life of sinful behavior no
that's not one doesn't follow from the
other and jesus christ demonstrated that
i took your nature but i will not
express your behavior i want you
to you and i we share the same nature
says christ but i want us also to have
the same behavior and that is possible
through total surrender to my father and
the indwelling power of the spirit
praise god i love that that that could
be a tagline jesus took our nature but
he did not take our behavior behave you
know he didn't
amen now we must take his behavior we
have the same nature at a human level
but we need to switch we need to take
his behavior
and we can do that by total surrender to
the father and i mean total and constant
praise god praise god
elder skeet we're moving on to our next
question and after this question i'll
take an open forum question because it's
in line with the one i'm about to ask
all right
the question is
will jesus retain his humanity
good question let's pray again father as
we continue this most important subject
possess our mind with our permission and
speak to us in jesus name i pray amen
the answer is yes
we go back to luke 24
and as they thus speak jesus himself
stood in the midst notice the word jesus
himself in the greek that's called the
intensive jesus himself the same one
they saw crucified the same one they saw
buried jesus himself stood in the midst
of them and said unto them peace be unto
you
but they were terrified and affrighted
and supposed that they had seen a spirit
a spirit is not physical christ had to
disabuse him of the notion that he was a
spirit that's why he said touch me
handle me look at my hand look at my
feet look at my side and he said give me
something to eat the risen jesus christ
was physical as verily as he was
physical before he died now the risen
christ had a glorified body all the
weakness is gone which is what we will
have according to philippians 3 20 and
21 and so yes jesus took his physical
nature to heaven with him that is why
the apostle paul can say in colossians 2
9 in him dwelleth the fullness of the
godhead bodily and paul is writing about
20 years after jesus christ returned to
heaven in uh colossians 1 verse 19 he
pleased the father that in him should
all fullness dwell and so colossians 2 9
colossians 1 19 the fullness of the
godhead dwells in a bodily person called
jesus christ first timothy 2 verse 5 for
there's one mediator one god and one
mediator between god and man the man
christ jesus jesus christ right now
has his physical uh nature his physical
flesh and blood and that's why i just
that's the thing i love
that there is i say so many times there
is a human being in the godhead called
jesus who is also god
but in christ we are represented with
godhead humanity elevated to that level
a privilege no angel can enjoy jesus
took his humanity to heaven that is why
before he died he told the disciples
nevertheless i tell you the truth it is
expedient for you that i go away for if
i go another way the comforter will not
come unto you why do they need the
comforter because the holy spirit can be
everywhere at the same time that's on
the present because christ took humanity
he laid down that ability of the
presence he cannot be everywhere at the
same time as i said he laid it down i
never said he lost it he laid it down
laid it aside and so he is still
encumbered restricted by human nature
cannot be everywhere the holy spirit is
his precise representative jesus christ
to human nature human condition his
physical form back to heaven with him we
have a flesh and blood high praise with
whom we can identify
we cannot identify with gabriel because
gabriel is not a human being we cannot
identify with him with the holy spirit
he's not a human being we identify with
jesus christ who is a man perfect man
sinless man having a glorified body but
a man nonetheless and we will have the
body he had when he came from the grave
right now i say as he listens to us
jesus christ is physical
as he is god
praise god praise god ah what love can
you believe like he said elder school
this is representation to the maximum
that we have a human being
in the godhead praise because we don't
believe these things
and without faith is impossible to
please god we don't believe they say we
function from the carnal nature not from
the possibilities of the divine and so
we try to change the gospel to
accommodate our weaknesses you see
because we just can't accept this
remarkable arrangement that someone who
fell can be elevated to so higher level
by the power of the gospel we cannot
accept it
and so we try to change the gospel to
suit our fallen condition and it's
really a tragic tragic way of behaving
another skeet i'm going to read this
quotation from desire
page 25 paragraph three
it says in taking our nature the savior
has bound himself to humanity by a tie
that is never to be broken broken that's
right through eternal ages
linked to us
god so loved the world that he gave his
only begotten son
he gave him not only to bear our sins
and to die as our sacrifice he gave him
to the fallen race yes to assure us of
his immutable counsel of peace
god gave his only begotten son
to become one of the human family
forever to return
that's right that's right this is the
pledge that god will fulfill his mm-hmm
praise god
yes praise god
um the question that sister juana had
when she say she got it now this was an
open forum open forum question
is when jesus was on earth did he
fluctuate between humanity and the
godhead
that's an interesting question it's very
cleverly phrased i don't know what she
means by fluctuate because both natures
were in operation at the same time
but there were times when divinity uh
were told flash through uh humanity
what we need to understand is in his
battle with sin
christ depended entirely on the father
did not resort to his divine nature he
rested entirely on the father for the
resources to overcome sin and the battle
was tremendous because satan knew who he
was now when christ accepted worship he
accepted worship as god because he never
ceased to be god when people prayed to
him he accepted that as god
but in his battle with satan and sin
christ depended on the father he
functioned from his humanity and that is
what concerns us because you and i will
never be god having people pray to us or
people confessing sins to us so that
does not apply to us his humanity that
is where he functioned in his battle
with sin and that's our concern the
battle we've seen our problem is sent
not listening to people pray to us or
forgiving people's sins our problem is
sin in the area of the confrontation
with sin the battle against satan christ
functioned fully from the human
depending and i have to keep stressing
entirely on the father so yes both
natures were in operation but christ
never used his divine power to resist
the devil or temptation or to fight his
enemies when he spat in his face he took
it as a human being when he slept him he
took it as a human being
when they insulted him he took it as a
human being
when peter raised the sword and cut off
the ear of the high priest jesus said
put up your sword you know he's
suggesting i can get myself out but i
don't need to do that he took all of
that as a human being
but he accepted worship as god
he forgave sins as god that's part of
the mystery but let me stress again in
the battle with sin which is our battle
in the battle of self and jesus
ourselves we see that when he said if it
be possible let this cup pass from me
nevertheless not my will but thing be
done he had self in that battle he
functioned as a human being depending
entirely i keep saying on the father and
entirely
amen amen
thank you all the skeet and thank you
sister juana for your question
um
i'm now going to allow sister janella
peters
to ask the next two questions pertaining
to the humanity of christ and these set
of questions specifically speak to the
impact christ's humanity has on us
this is janella you may ask the next
questions thank you
amen so our next question
our next question will be
what is the role of christ humanity in
the plan of salvation
that is as significant as any question
can be
without the humanity of christ there is
no salvation
because salvation is god's response to
sin he had to find a way to save sinners
from the condemnation which is death the
law declares
he which or she who transgresses the law
must die there is no other
divine response to sins and death god
and the son defies a way to deliver
mankind from that condemnation and
since it is death someone had to die
the death penalty can never be
eliminated it is simply relocated let me
say that again the death penalty
salvation does not cancel the death
penalty it relocates the death penalty
from the sinner to christ let me add
another word from the repentant sinner
the surrendered sinner to christ the
death penalty god's law is so holy it is
so uh
righteous like god himself so sacred
that the penalty for that law cannot be
canceled it can simply be relocated the
plan of salvation moves the penalty from
the sinner to jesus christ from the
repentant surrendered sinner to christ
someone has to die now god cannot die
or you follow me god cannot die god has
god is immortality itself first timothy
6 16 he cannot die god is life
the plan of salvation required that god
come in a form that would allow
him to die so he took human form in his
humanity
the creator died let me say carefully
divinity cannot die
but
the human christ was as much god as the
divine you see there were two persons
one person two different natures in his
humanity christ given his life
through his divinity he came back let me
say it again through his humanity christ
could give up his life and so the
humanity of christ was absolutely
censored but even before he gave up the
life in his humanity he could feel what
it needs to be tempted because we know
from james 1 13 let no man say when i'm
tempted when he's tempted i am tempted
of god for god cannot be tempted with
evil neither temptee any man it is
impossible to tempt god
but to save us the savior had to
experience what is it like to be tempted
and since god cannot be tempted human
created beings can be tempted god came
in the form of a creative being lower
than the angels a human being in the
human being's fallen condition and so
the humility of christ was absolutely
indispensable to the gospel remove the
humanity there is no salvation christ
had to be human so that he saved he
became what he saved or he saved what
was his
amen and that gives us tremendous
comfort today that you have a god in
heaven who's also mad
the very if you if some young man listen
to me i was tempted to go to some dirty
porn site you know
whatever he's feeling christ understands
even though there were there weren't any
form sites in the days of jesus christ
but there were temptations to do this
all that that temptation jesus
understand if you're tempted to cheat on
your taxes jesus understand you're
tempted to do whatever jesus understands
why he can say well i am one of you i
understand because i live like you the
humanity of jesus christ allows him to
understand and to sympathize not to
agree with sin but to sympathize with
the struggling sinner and to say i know
what you're going through and i can help
you through it uh hebrews 2 verse 18 for
him that he himself have suffered being
tempted he's able to sucker them that
attempted he can help you because he
knows exactly what you're going through
he suffered it the only difference is he
never yielded
and he can show you how to stop healing
the humanity of christ i say again is
absolutely indispensable to the gospel
remove the humanity there is no gospel
remove the divinity there is no gospel
they have to go together
and the immediate jesus christ
amen i definitely agree and two verses
comes to mind uh the first one
john 3 verse 16 and 17 for god so loved
the world that he gave his only begotten
son
that whosoever believeth him shall not
perish but have everlasting life
and verse 17 this is the key for god
sent not his son into the world to
condemn the world but that the world
through him might be faced all right so
god's plan of salvation is to redeem us
not to
uh condemn us that's right
and the second verse that comes to mind
is hebrews 4 15 and you touched on that
that we have a high priest in heaven
that
has felt that is feeling our infirmities
that's right has been tempted in all
points like we are yet he did not sin
so because of his example
that he has laid before us we know it is
very possible to overcome sin but as he
said we must commit our whole will to
god
that's right that's right
thank you and this brings us to our uh
last question uh how does christ
humanity help us be partakers of the
divine nature
all right
we have to partake of the divine nature
that occurs when we unite with jesus
christ because remember both natives are
in him now partaking of the divine
nature does not make me god and i must
say this very clearly no created being
can be god
but we must be as godlike as we possibly
can this is god's desire for us be as
much like me as you can but you cannot
be me for one reason no created being
can be god and so we know from education
18 verse 4 higher than the highest human
thought can reaches god's ideal for his
children godliness god likeness is the
goal to be reached if you read of
hebrews 12 verse 10 we must partake of
this holiness the nation read in
philippians 2 verse 5 let this mind be
in you which was also in christ jesus
the very mind christ have we must have
the holiness of god we must have and of
course we must partake of the divine
nature ii peter chapter 1 verse 4
whereby are given to us exceeding great
and precious promises that by these he
might be partakers of the divine nature
through the indwelling of the word of
god which is how jesus dwells in us we
partake of the divine nature because the
life of the word of god is the life of
god let me say that again
when we receive the word of god
and when by receive i mean study and
obey not just memorize a bible
study and obey when we receive the word
of god we are receiving something that
contains the very life of god john 6 63
it is the spirit that quickeneth
quickness means gives life the flesh
of nothing the words that i speak unto
you they are spirit and they are life
when you receive that word you receive
the very life of god and let me repeat
receive it by studying and obeying
someone who only studies but does not
obey is not receiving the word of god is
not receiving the life of god the person
is just receiving condemnation because
you study you refuse to obey but when we
study and obey
the life imparted to us is the life of
god that's how we partake of the divine
nature in john 5 30 jesus said and ye
have not his word abiding in you for
whom he has said he may receive not but
god is saying jesus christ is saying
because you don't receive me you don't
have my word in you to receive christ is
to receive the word that's how we
partake of the divine nature
you know i made a very interesting
statement in uh education 126 paragraph
four the divine energy the creative
energy that called the worlds into
existence is in the word of god
this word imparts power it begets life
every command is a promise accepted by
the will received into the soul it
brings with it the life of the infinite
one there are some statements of the
bible in the spiritual prophecy that are
so astonishing that we tend to back away
from believing that when you receive
god's word through study and obedience
you receive the life of god let me say
it differently you receive the very life
of that tree for which adam was allowed
to eat before he sinned
we partake of divine nature through
surrender to the word of god which has
surrendered to christ who is the word
in which means outside of the bible you
and i cannot partake of the divine
nature the christian who ignores god's
bible
is ignoring the divine nature of god
you may go to church every sabbath you
have no time for the bible you have no
time for god
amen
it's only by studying god's word
eating it daily and obeying studying and
obeying it
yes
he's able to create his uh renew his
image in us absolutely yes
thank you eldeski uh this is the last
question uh how does chrysler manatee
help us be partakers of divine nature
um i would now turn it over to sister
denisha for
our open forum questions
i only want questions on the humanity of
christ on this subject is so important
don't ask me about who can marry only on
the humanity of jesus christ please
amen amen indeed indeed
all right so let me there was one that
came in okay
roger
brother rod rodger has asked will christ
be limited
with space so i guess buy space forever
yes yes
by his own choice
are you with me by his own choice jesus
christ cannot be everywhere at the same
time because he has laid aside this
tremendous capacity called omnipresence
and so in the new world you see christ
tells us in john 14 1-3 let not your
heart be troubled you believe in god
believe also in me in my father's house
are many mansions if it were not so i
would have told you i go to prepare a
place for you and if i go and prepare a
place for you i will come again and
receive you unto myself that where i am
there you may be also christ is
somewhere physically the holy spirit is
everywhere we can't explain that jesus
christ is saying virtually you are not
where i am
and i want you where i am and he can say
that because of the limitation placed on
him by his voluntarily taking human
nature and voluntarily setting aside
omnipresence so jesus christ will
forever
forever as long as he has human
condition
be limited by this inability to be
everywhere at the same time it is part
of the cost
to save wretches like you and i
jesus christ
has voluntarily accepted imagine
divinity limited he's accepted the
limitations of humanity in order to save
us
how can we escape
if we neglect so great salvation he will
be limited
in the sense that he cannot be
everywhere
at the same time
praise god what condescension
what kind of ascension no other religion
has a god who does that no other
religious system on the face of the
earth has a god who does that who comes
down to us
to lift us up
all of the gods tell you come up christ
came down first and i'll take you up
he is jacob's ladder he's jacob's ladder
praise he came down they said now let's
go up
amen you know many of us say no no let's
stay down many of us say let's stay down
john 3 19 and this is the condemnation
that light is coming to the world and
men love darkness rather than light
christ came to the gutter weary and said
come on let me pick you up and many of
us say no i'm accustomed to the gather
stay here with me but no no christ isn't
staying there with you he came to get
you out of it
many of us don't want to be lifted and
it'll be our loss on the day of judgment
but yes you'll be limited for all
eternity because he'll be human for all
it's still god but human as well
amen amen you know elder skeet as you
made that that point i thought of the
angels and lot when he was trying to get
his son-in-laws to get out of sodom and
they're like no no no
we have everything here we don't want to
move yes we do we often do the same
thing to jesus
not realizing the time of our visitation
that indeed judgment is coming not only
the physical not only did they refuse to
go physically
but the lot wise lost wife left
physically but not spiritually her mind
was still in sodom so she was
effectively as lost as her sons-in-law
and we have to be careful you know we
must be physically and mentally
separated from the world many of us are
in the church but our minds are in the
world we follow this we follow the
fashion we follow the celebrities we
follow this athlete we are we are
mentally still in the world we miss the
world we're physically in the church
this is as dangerous as not coming to
church at all
we are
mentally still in the world as lord's
wife was mentally still in sodom even or
physically out
you've got to come out
mentally and physically
amen and as we stated before that's how
we show that we are partakers of the
divine nature
come out of babylon
live for christ
all right
our next question comes comes from
christian chris jan dulk
uh his question is when were the sins of
humanity transferred to christ was this
at gethsemane
that gets 70
and on the cross
christ
bore the sins of the world
the father forsook him on the cross not
in gethsemane in gethsemane
christ saw what he would have to suffer
he trembled that's why he almost right
back he trembled when he saw what he had
to suffer he had to drink that cup of
suffering he trembled and trembled so
part of that was in gaffe 78 on the
cross the father forsaken the father
didn't forsake him in the garden the
father sent an angel to strengthen him
to get into the cross
and so mainly at the cross but part of
it was also in the garden of 70 where he
swear blood but on the cross dying as a
sinner we never chose to sin dying or
someone made sin ii corinthians 5 21 the
father turned away he couldn't look at
it
i didn't say the father went back the
father at the cross but turned away from
him and in the darkness but the father
was there but turned away and how do we
know the father turned away jesus said
why hast thou forsaken me and that was
no lie the father had to forsake him for
that time the same way the father has to
forsake sin and those of us who refuse
christ one day we will experience this
why hastily forsaken me let me not say
we those of us who refuse to accept
christ will one day experience that
anguish both in gethsemane and the cross
but on that cross that's where he died
as a sinner because in gethsemane he
could have changed his mind
but there's no changing of mind on that
cross
amen amen
thank you all the skeet and i love first
second corinthians 5 21 where he
literally says that jesus became sin
the very thing that separates us from
god god made him to be sin for us
which means he doesn't choose to be he
was made sin he was made in the lord he
was made all this same he never chose
this he never chose to sin and we can
also choose not to sin
i have the power to carry out that
choice the power of christ
amen amen all right i see that uh
brother kelly edwards has raised his
hands further kelly you may ask your
question if it pertains specifically to
[Music]
give me one one second this is my second
opportunity again to speak to randy
skeet so i must say mr randy man i love
your ministry i love you god bless you
god bless you you know it always
inspires me to you know i'm so mad at
soon you'll be going to my country and i
can't even be there in the end
but um my question is right um does
christ
still appears
to people
individually like he did with john
you know like how he appeared and he
speak to john does he still do that like
in visions or in person or in dreams but
he did it with adam why he certainly did
now he may have you see he may do it and
we not know you understand what i can
say to you is god's primary means of
communication to us is not dreams and
visions but his word
god will not institute a system of
communication that rarely gets his word
to second place he will not do that
because the word created the universe
the word sustains the universe the word
is above the very name of god christ
himself is the word we must always
remember god's primary means of
communication is the word but on
isolated occasions god can decide to
appear to someone in a dream or vision
he can do that but that must never take
the place of the word of god yes christ
has the freedom to appear to anyone if
he so chooses but let me say again his
primary means of contact and
communication
is the word of god god will do nothing
that makes a pathway for us to skirt
around studying and obeying his work but
he can choose to appear on some
occasions because he's gone
let me
allow him to
okay there you go brother thank you
appreciate you pastor you're welcome my
brother god bless you
thank you what country are you from
uh from guyana
okay amen amen thank you elders keaton
thank you brother edwards for asking
your question and now i must say my
parents are actually from guyana so oh
yes yes praise god praise god
uh we have some more questions
um i see someone sent me a note that uh
jerry2x45 has sent a question on youtube
i'm not seeing it but i recall that he
was on i believe he's one of the others
at cornerstone sda i'm not seeing that
question so sister stacy if you can put
that question in the chat
i would appreciate that
um in the meantime i'll take this
question from june
to beleka
oh that's my sister that's my little
sister oh that's my sweet little sister
ah all right
ah praise god well thank you so much
amen okay
god bless june
amen so the question is okay so this
question pertains to the humanity of
jesus yes god by definition needs
nothing
it's perfect in his being
man needs god and man also needs food
oxygen and other elements to function
how do these things exist at the same
time if jesus is a man in heaven does he
eat does his body still perform human
bodily functions mm-hmm
i should say that june is a medical
doctor so he can understand why she
would ask those questions
she is a child of god and a medical
doctor her family she's from the uganda
the whole family i spent time with them
twice back in the early 20s before you
were born up to indonesia and so
okay
now
there are human beings in heaven
no i'm not noah moses
elijah eno and jesus christ now there
were human beings who went up with
christ after his resurrection
we don't know what the number was so
they are physical human beings in heaven
the bible tells us men did eat angels
food he sent the meat to the full uh
psalm 78 i believe is verse 25 now we
cannot assume angels don't eat we cannot
assume that
uh because we know two angels came with
abraham and they consume something but
it's in human form we cannot assume
categorically angels don't eat human
beings were made to eat let me say it
again human beings were made to eat in
the new world we will eat and white
tells us when we get to heaven one of
the first things that will happen is a
dinner where christ himself served and
we will leave i cannot account for the
minute biological functions because they
change things in us but i can i can say
yes people in heaven eat
manna had never been seen on the earth
until it fell 40 years in the wilderness
when they crossed jordan in the canaan
land the manor ceased this was a
miraculous provision the bible calls it
angel sword now so we we cannot dismiss
the fact that human beings eat
in heaven
what exactly they eat we don't know but
human beings were created to eat and
that life is preserved by the tree of
life which is in heaven right now it
shall be brought back down let me say it
again
in eternal life this immortality
is preserved by constantly eating of the
tree of life
and so there is some system of eating in
heaven for human beings who live there
and quite possibly for angels does the
holy spirit need to eat no does god the
father need to eat no
will christ eat well he's human and it's
not a make-believe humanity he is he it
is astonishing to think we will discover
when we get to the other side christ is
still human
as we will be
that glorified humanity when we rise
from the dead or are translated and so
my response to my lovely sister's
question is yes
human beings eat
and there's evidence that angels eat
but i cannot account for all the
biological functions because sin brought
about changes i mean for for trees to
start producing thorns they had to be a
genetic change in in the plants you see
to them produce thorns and thistles
which never occurred before sin and so
as there were changes in plants there
were changes in human beings as well
so since change some things we'll go
back to the originals
amen amen back to the i'm very excited
to hear that sister june asks a question
i really am
ah praise god praise god
thank you i should say dr june that's
right that's right
all right i see prince eli you have your
hand raised
once again as it is once it is
pertaining to the the humanity of christ
you may ask your question i have now
needed you
when i was memorizing the
um
john chapter 14 i came across this test
said
okay go meeting and
i want to ask them
go on
i think it's pertaining to the divinity
of christ i think versus 20 it says
that they shall know that i am in my
father
and he and me
i in you
john 17. i didn't understand that it's
christ that he's
john chapter 14 verse 20. no that's john
johnson
14 john 17
chapter 17 of john but it's okay go on
okay
so let's see
read the read the verse again read the
verse again
the best
is yes he's the same as the father and
it cried i i was confused when i was
getting this okay all right now
no christ is not the same as the father
this is very very clear jesus christ and
the father are two
separate personalities
but they are one
in mind in heart in ambition in program
in functioning there is no discord
between the father and the son there are
one in that sin the bible says in
genesis 2 24 therefore shall a man leave
his father and mother and shall save to
his wife and they shall be one flesh so
as adam and eve were one but two
separate individuals surely that is a
reflection of the higher form of that
oneness being the father and the son
they are not the same individual they
are different individuals but they're
they function as one the united states
has one military force not two but we
have marines uh air force navy and army
but it is one military force all right
and so the christ is in the father in a
sense that christ has always been one
with the father the father dwells in him
that's what he said in john 14 verse 10
believers thou not that i am in the
father and the father in me that's what
he said in the very same chapter the
words that i speak unto you i speak not
of myself but the father that dwelleth
in me now this must be our experience
with christ galatians 2 20 i am
crucified with christ nevertheless i
live yet not i but christ live within me
that simply means oneness in the sense
that a total surrender to a person we
can be one in christ as verily as christ
was one with the father yet we are
separate individuals the believer and
christ are two separate individuals but
we can be in christ and christ in us
that's the way there is the father and
the son and through christ you see if
we're in christ and christ is in the
father we're in the father so the verse
says at that day he shall not have i'm
in my father and me and i in you it's
mysterious but it's a reality
that because christ is in the father and
we're in christ we are in the father's
world
remarkable astonishing it challenges uh
the mind to accept that by faith there's
no way to accept it but by faith
suppose
christ giving us a standard of god to
live like a god
because ellen white said and i think
christ object lesson
and without that we can never see god
give me that standard
does christ do what
it's christ giving us um requiring us to
live that perfect humanity he lived on
earth when he came here absolutely said
he lived on earth the life christ lives
on earth
is the life required of us with respect
to his battle of sin he totally
conquered sin he totally obeyed his
father he offers that life to us
let me say let me get my wording very
carefully that life is lived out through
us as we remain surrendered to christ
we cannot live that life in our own we
can't do that we can live decent lives
we can live morally upright lives
but a lot of atheists are morally
upright and they're decent but the life
that christ lives that life has to be
lived out in us through the indwelling
of christ and christ indwells us as we
remain surrendered to him and so i say
again through total surrender christ can
live up that life in us as verily as
through total surrender the father lived
out the life in christ let me give you
john 14 10 again believers thou not that
i am in the father and the father may
the words that i speak unto you i speak
not of myself but the father that
brothers in me
he does the words
so christ was the instrument of the
father to raise the dead the instrument
of the father to heal the sin christ is
the instrument whereby we come to sin he
is the instrument revived we pray for
the sick and the secret here christ
christ we are the instrument i should
say that christ uses to express his life
the life christ lives on this earth is
without variation the life that
qualifies us for a place in god's
kingdom and as the father lives in
christ christ must live in us
six and one half dozen
we cannot lower that standard
thank you pastor god bless you you're
welcome god bless you my handsome
brother god bless you
yeah
amen amen thank you skeet for that
response um it is 303 so i am just going
to take this question
all right from
uh brother jerry that sister stacy has
put in the chat sister stacey hensford
um brother jerry's question is if we are
saved by jesus's blood
and the life of the flesh is in the
blood
is it saying that we are saved by his
perfect life absolutely absolutely oh
that's a very good question oh god bless
that person who put that question we
keep thinking of blood blood blood let
me say this but let me pray again father
as we come to the conclusion don't cut
off your wisdom brand it to us i pray
please in jesus name amen if you read
luke 22 verse 43
and his sweat was as it were great drops
of blood falling down to the ground i
believe verse 44 of luke 22. now jesus
shed blood in gethsemane are you with me
that
was that enough to save us no
no he shed blood in his family
i'm sure he said okay when he was
whipped by pilots or soldiers he shed
blood
he was uh what's the word he was uh they
used a catalytic tail he tore his back
he shed blood
but he did not get given his life so
it's not just blood blood hemoglobin
we're discussing the blood represents
the life of jesus christ death is the
method by which he poured out his life
we are saved by the life of jesus christ
when people say the blood of christ yes
we underst we hope we should understand
the blood refers to the life
we are saved by the life when someone is
healed that person is healed by the life
of jesus christ a tree is kept alive by
the life of christ or the life of god
life is what saves us the life of jesus
christ how can he give that life for us
to pave the penalty of the law death was
the method whereby he poured out his
life uh isaiah 53 he poured out his life
it is the life of christ let me ask this
if christ had not risen from the dead
what good with his death have done
nothing absolutely nothing and so yes we
we thanks christ uh god for the death of
christ but he rose to apply his life
the victorious life and so the blood of
christ is the life of christ when we're
forgiven our sins are removed and the
life of christ is applied in its place
the power to resist sin is the life of
christ the power of the word of god is
the life of christ the power of creation
is the life of christ it is the life of
christ and the blood simply means the
life the life is in the blood now you
say it's a carrier death was the means
whereby he poured out his life
it is the life of christ that saves us
amen and he poured it out through this
thing called death when i said death he
wasn't killed he gave up his life i need
to say that very clearly christ wasn't
killed he gave up his life
he gave it up
remarkable tremendous unselfishness he
gave that's why he said destroy this
temple in three days i will raise it up
i have power to lay down i have power to
take it up again no man takes it from me
john 1080 no man and so yes i hate to
keep going on like this but that
question is so significant it is the
life of christ the life
of christ
amen
when a sinner brought an animal in an
old testament system
the animal was killed that wasn't the
end of it the priest represented the
risen christ the
living priest had to take that blood and
apply the blood yes it is the life of
christ
amen so the question actually continued
on all right to read so which we must
strive for that was the perfect life of
christ which we address with prince
eli's question
the second part says and if christ died
for our sins
is it double jeopardy for us to pay the
penalty for our own sins
no it's not double jeopardy
if christ died for your sins
he rose
that total sacrifice which is absolutely
acceptable to god
when you accept christ's savior you
accept all of that
you don't have to die for your sins you
accept what christ did for you and i
mean you accepted all your heart with
all your soul your mind your strength
your understanding and your might every
mitochondrial in your body is
surrendered to that fact that christ
died for you you accept that
you you don't have to pay the penalty at
all now you may die the physical death
that's a consequence that's not the
penalty for death i mean lazarus died
christ raised him he died again abraham
died noah died you know david died and
they're all dead that's not the penalty
for sin the penalty is what jesus
suffered in gethsemane and when he
voluntarily laid down his life
you don't have to suffer that if you
accept christ 100
i have to hammer that into the heads of
my listeners 100
so you don't have to suffer that no
there's no double jeopardy whatever
degree of jeopardy jesus took it on that
you don't have to
that's why he's a substitute
he took your place
you have to accept that with all of your
heart
and for those elders that reject jesus
would they be suffering double jeopardy
or no
no you don't suffer therefore do you
suffer what is coming to you you see the
soul of sinneth it shall die you suffer
what's coming perhaps i don't understand
what the person means by double jeopardy
you don't die twice for sin you suffer
the penalty of the law because you've
rejected jesus christ that's what you
suffer from you know what he felt in
your ceremony on that cross that's what
you'll suffer
that total separation from god and then
blasted out by the fires of hell that's
what the sinner suffers
that's not double jeopardy that's a
penalty for sin
amen amen
you know
preaching does not stress enough the
punishment for rejecting christ
everyone wants nice servants that say
here's how to be racist how to be
married here's out whatever they don't
want to hear about there's a punishment
side the most popular bible verse says
for god so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son that whosoever
believeth in him should not perish what
is involved in perish the flames of hell
that is the perishing
but no one wants to hear that
and it's a disservice not to preach
there's a hell it is a disservice
because it provides a motivation to
avoid hell now yes our primary
motivation must be to be in heaven with
christ but we need to understand there's
another side
there's another sign
and when people know consequences it
enables them to make intelligent choices
if you know you know in canada there's
some very severe consequences of
speeding when you know that you watch
your speed they can confiscate your car
right on the side of the road depending
on how fast you were going and then the
fines are heavy if you know that then
you'll watch your behavior and so
there's a positive and a negative the
positive is i want to be with jesus the
negative is i do not want to burn alive
they're both sides
one is stronger than the other my real
motivation is i want to be of jesus
forever but i certainly don't want to
burn in hell but the bible warns us
there's something called hell and people
need to know
people need to know
but no one wants to know just tell me
how sweet jesus is don't tell me about
hell well okay
okay
you'll just be surprised that's
all yeah
next question
this question comes from brother oliver
he asks
why was the personal and it sees
personally but i'm not too sure about
the form there but why was a personal
nature of jesus christ uh why were these
two things not accepted in 1888
who said they were not accepted
well some accepted some did
some accepted some didn't
and so i will avoid making a blanket
statement it was not accepted some
accepted some didn't but that goes all
as far back as when christ came to where
the gospel as far as the gospel reaches
we have this reaction to the gospel some
accept some didn't
some accepted the dual nature of christ
some didn't some accepted the dual
nature with modifications to his human
nature we have all these reactions to
the gospel of jesus christ
some accepted the pure truth some didn't
and that will continue until jesus comes
but each individual has a very very
serious responsibility to study for
himself or herself because my study
won't save you you have to study and
i've observed in my travels people
will not take the time to study that
i've made this criticism before it is
easy to say tell me
genesis 1 1 in the beginning god what
does that mean tell me i'm not studying
i have other things to do just tell me
some accept some don't simple as that
amen amen
well elder skeet
i do see one more question but
3 13 and so i'm going to okay it's okay
it's okay it's all right i'll make this
the final question this is from the
sovereign hero
and what other ways has taken on
humanity well this person when he said
mar the god mard the godhead i don't
think it necessarily has martin
but
i'll read the second part was christ
gargantuan and stature before taking on
humanity
um
okay let me i don't know if i understand
this in other words has was christ's
stature reduced when he took on humanity
uh that's a good question uh i don't
have a bible verse uh if the person is
an adventist i know eloise tells us that
before christ came to the earth he was
taller than all the angels
taller than all of them
when he came to the earth he was
slightly taller than the average man in
his time slightly taller
in the new world he'd be taller than
adam and so height is uh is also an
expression a symbol of a christ position
you look at male and female relationship
male headship god made men generally
taller than women and stronger and
that's a part of the image of god that
the god is higher and taller
than the angels will be created the
unfallen beings now i don't know if when
elohim tells us in the new world when
the first adam meets the second christ
is taller than adam
and the last so everyone looks up to
christ if i can put it that way
nice the last part of the question is
does jesus have to partake of the tree
of life
have some smart people on this forum
ah how do i answer that i know that in
his humanity
jesus will eat
that's all i'll say it is humanity
christ now we have the particularly life
i don't know if jesus has
you see there's something about the
humanity of christ i won't go so far as
to say as christ humanity was identical
to us in every microscopic detail
because the suffering christ endured in
gethsemane
no other human being could have endured
because the bible said the father
prepared the body for him the suffering
christ endured no average human being
could have endured
somewhere ella white writes
justice demanded the sufferings of a man
christ render the sufferings of a god in
his human condition so i cannot say that
in every microscopic detail the body of
christ was exactly like ours what i can
say in the battle of sin it was and so
jesus
christ whether he'll partake of the tree
of life as a human being i don't know
what i do know is human beings eat
we have to partake of the tree of life
amen
it could be because he's got a man he
can sustain himself through his divinity
we won't be gone and man we'll just be
man
you see christ will still be gone and
now
and so i can't see if you'll eat of the
tree of life but i do know human beings
eat and christ is human
but not a heal but that's not saying he
has to eat to maintain his life
christ is god while he's human it's part
of the mystery so i i can't give a
definitive response all i can say is we
do redeemed we will eat of the tree of
life
and when we get to heaven and christ
serves us surely he'll eat with us
in his human condition he'll eat with us
amen amen so elders
yes made that the final question was
there another question
there are more questions coming in the
chat uh pick a good one pick a good one
pick a good one a good one and ask it
yes one that can bless a lot of people
use in your estimation
in my estimation you know to be honest
we've answered pretty much all of them
and someone said another question a
follow-up on the
double jeopardy one so
yes what does it say
it says so would it be double jeopardy
paying twice for a crime which is not
allowed in heavenly in earthly courts
but we are paying the penalty for the
unpardonable sin rejecting him the sin
which he did not die for
no if double gently means pain twice you
do not pay twice for sin you pay once
now we suffer the consequences of sin as
we live even christians do that
but the penalty for sin for those who
reject christ will come when all sins
are finally destroyed and they
experience that total separation from
god which no human being has ever
experienced except jesus christ so if
double jfd needs to pay twice no you'll
pay once and it is final
but you don't have to pay that christ
played it except christ
absolutely totally completely 100
percent accept jesus christ give every
area of your life to his control
so that his payment is credited to your
account
amen amen
thank you so much elder steve for
taking us on this journey through the
leading of the holy spirit
and the humanity of christ we see the
great condescension of our lord and
savior
taking on our form so that we can
partake of his divinity
my sister registered beverly registered
henry in the chat has said may god
continue to bless you elder skeet all
right praying for god's blessings on
your life and ministry no denisha
let me uh let me recommend a book for
your listeners dr denisha yes it is
called the consecrated way i think the
holiness by eighty jones
one of our great
second generation pioneers
read that book read it carefully
prayerfully read it in connection with
hebrews chapters one and two
and in connection with the desire of
ages and christ object lessons and steps
of christ and see what you learn
do an intense study of hebrews chapter 1
which highlights the divinity of christ
hebrews chapter 2 the humanity of christ
and you can't separate these two
chapters
i recommend it i think it's called the
consecrated way of holiness your local
bookstore should have it by eighty jones
thank you obviously i'm not a
spokesperson for the abc i'm just
promoting that book
amen thank you the consecrated way to
holy holiness by a.j a.t jones
thank you so much elder skeet
again we say thank you for your time all
right okay dedication to this ministry
we know that
you are in high demand you just came
back from ghana not too long ago yes
have a blessed time bless your time in
ghana god bless god and every ghanaian
everywhere i had a simply
blessed time in ghana
amen amen freedom from fair that was the
theme yes yes
and now i'm hearing you'll be going to
guyana the lord willing
my god it's great so thank you for
spending the time with us here
and always even going over for the sake
of the gospel may the lord continue to
bless you your wife and entire family as
you are
fervently for christ for the cause of
christ
thank you thank you thank you god bless
you my sister i mean god bless you in
every possible way bless your studies
bless your life
bless your family and bless this
ministry god has given to you and let me
say to those who listen
don't just listen as a way to help you
by time
think of what you heard
study the texts
look at your relationship between you
and your savior what kind of
relationship do you have it is simply go
to church on saturday for two hours and
do whatever you like in the week
christ is coming back this is no joke
don't be so busy making a life you
forget to prepare for the life to come
jesus christ is coming back he's not
coming back to get people ready he's
coming back to those who have given
themselves to him now that he through
their surrender might make them ready be
ready for the return of christ
and the only way to be ready is to
surrender to him and accept him as your
savior
and your lord may god bless all of you
and put a double blessing on your
children
amen amen thank you other skeet for
pronouncing that blessing and while
we're here i might as well thank all of
you that have tuned in today i see there
are some persons from at least one from
ohio claire bliss thank you for joining
brother short mcfly thank you brother
akeem for my church east new york thank
you for tuning in
sister stacy cumberbatch who said she
would be on thank you for being here and
evangelist f baxter um caleb
viegas all of you that are here on
youtube and even on the zoom thank you
for your presence sister rose petal and
the list goes on thank you sister
janella for asking the questions those
two questions
um to elder skeet and brother kevin
gomez in advance thank you for
ministering this song whether kevin
gomez will be ministering broken and
spilled out and i am i'm ready to
receive that blessing and song and thank
you sister talexia cox in advance who's
just a youth i believe 13 years old
thank you in advance for doing the
closing prayer um mom thank you for your
prayers support counsel even helping me
set up this new desk so that i can focus
my eyes on the camera as much as
possible and thank you for your words of
counsel and support to all of you that
are here may god continue to bless you
and keep you and indeed may we become
partakers of the divine nature as we
leave this q a session may we embody and
really just marinate and meditate on the
things that we have learned that jesus
indeed took the form of human nature
after adam fell to show that we have the
power through the holy spirit to
overcome sin may we make our decisions
based on that power based on that
impetus that god has given us to be
victorious over sin
once again thank you elder skeet and may
god continue to shower you thank you
abundantly
we will now be blessed with the peace by
brother kevin gomez
broken
and spilled out
do
one day
a plane billet woman
driven
by love for her lord
she recklessly
poured out
disregarding
the scorn
and once
it was broken
and split out
a fragrance
separated
[Music]
jesus
oh
me
[Music]
is
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
and oh
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
the club
[Music]
for me
amen he came here to die for us
so we can have eternal life
ah
amen broken and spilled out that's what
jesus was for us thank you brother kevin
gomez for ministering that song and i
can't wait till we
we are in the courts of heaven when we
can minister and experience even the
vibrations of the of the notes that come
out of our mouths and glory and honor to
our maker and king unimpeded by
technology or any attack of the enemy
where we can freely experience the
worship of our lord and savior thank you
brother kevin gomez for ministering
broken
and spilled out before we take our
closing prayer i just want to invite all
of you to join us by god's grace
sabbath january 25 at 2 o'clock p.m
eastern standard time for a q a with
professor walter fight on country living
and the crisis ahead once again country
living and the crisis ahead
sister stacy and brown will be asking
the questions with me brother yuri
montos who i believe is 11 years old
will be ministering a piece on piano and
brother sean williams will be doing our
closing prayer and of course professor
walter fight will be answering the
questions on country living and the
crisis ahead you can join via zoom
the id is there 679-742-1793
the password is one two three four five
seven you can also use the call number
to tune in and as always this q a will
be live by god's grace on youtube
facebook twitter and twitch the last two
at the word inspired
so feel free to take a screenshot of
this flyer so it can be disseminated and
save the date so that we can tune in
this will be at two o'clock p.m eastern
standard time i see there's no time here
but it will be at two o'clock p.m
eastern standard time by god's
grace all right
thank you all again sister talexia scott
you may do the closing prayer
let us pray
father and i want to thank you
for another opportunity we have to come
before you at this moment as i come to
you today i ask you to forgive me of all
my sins as i send this prayer to you
lord please forgive the sins of all
those who are joining in this program
i want to thank you for another
opportunity we have to join in this q a
each question acts on the top of the
humanity of christ lord i
thank you for leading pastor skeet as he
explained each question to your guidance
may we continue to allow you to lead us
and may your holy spirit lead and direct
us as we allow you to be the main leader
of our
lives in jesus name amen
amen amen thank you so much sister cox
for joining us all the way from jamaica
and rendering that closing prayer to all
of you once again who joined
thank you and for those of you that will
watch the replay thank you for those of
you that will share thank you and for
those of you that will subscribe
thank you may we do our part
to spread the everlasting gospel in all
the worlds thank you brother emmanuel
yaboa for that prayer
sister cassandra james as always thank
you for your support brother emmanuel
john saba
um sister
well i'm not sure if this is a male or
female but m hurley thank you for tuning
in as well
to all of you may god bless you and
please do enjoy the rest of this sabbath
day
and may we look forward
to that time when time will be no more
and we will spend the ceaseless ages of
eternity in the presence of our lord and
savior until then be well and god bless